welcome to another Q&A episode of the
stronger by science podcast in today's
episode Greg and I field listener
questions about how the my own nuclear
domain theory relates to hypertrophy
sodium bicarbonate supplementation using
bands for hypertrophy training and more
in addition I defend my honor my
integrity and my original review of the
game-changers movie in response to some
very harsh criticism if you want your
questions answered on a future episode
you can go to tiny dot CC / SPS QA to
submit those questions as always thank
you for listening and enjoy the show
[Music]
welcome back to another Q&A episode of
the stronger by science podcast we have
a lot of good questions today so we are
gonna dive right into it so the first
question is for Greg it is from a user
whose name is land ho the question is I
would love to hear Greg's take on the
current state of the literature
regarding the Myo nuclear
domain theory and hypertrophy it seems
like there's some new evidence that my
own nuclei accretion may not necessarily
precede hypertrophy I would also love to
hear Greg's updated recommend
recommendations from the grow like a
newbie article that he wrote back in
2015 yeah so - to start off with
answering this question I I'd recommend
at least going back and checking out the
article I wrote back in 2015
title is grow like a new lifter again it
is probably the most controversial
article that I've written for the site a
lot of people read it and a lot of
people got upset about it I think
because I used a clickbait title and
they just purely assess the article on
those grounds instead of like actually
reading it closely which you know to be
fair I understand that's the game you
play when you go with clickbait titles
but anyway the the kernel of that
article just two very very briefly
summarize it is that your muscles are
fairly unique as cells in your body in
that most of your cells only have one
nucleus and your muscle fibers are just
very large individual cells that have
multiple nuclei I know that like maybe
one of the larger immune cells also has
multiple nuclei and maybe like one or
two other cell types but your your
muscle fibers are one of the very very
few cells in your body that is
multinucleated and so my own nuclear
domain theory is the idea that
essentially how large a muscle fiber can
get is at least to some degree
constrained by the number of my own
nuclei
it has that there is essentially each my
own nuclei can have a given domain and
it essentially works like a Wi-Fi router
within that domain where for a given
basically amount of area surrounding
that nucleus that that nucleus can you
know control the goings-on in the cell
can code for the proteins needed to
maintain that given volume of sarcoplasm
and that if the muscle fiber expands too
much and like the size of the muscle
fiber got larger than its number of my
nuclei could kind of support and signal
and create proteins for then essentially
things would start breaking down and
functioning less efficiently and
therefore that seems to be pretty
constrained we're passed a given point
for muscle fibers to continue growing
they need to keep adding more my own
nuclei so that the Myo nuclear domains
don't get too large and so what I argued
in the article is something that's a
slight obsession of mine which is a
frustrating obsession because there's
not much research on it one way or
another is basically the question of why
we stopped growing in the first place
like you know we know if you're a new
lifter you lift weights you get bigger
you get a little bit more advanced you
keep lifting weights you keep getting
bigger but at a slower rate and then it
seems like for you know pretty much
everyone eventually you reach a point
where like you just can't add more
muscle or you're adding muscle it's such
a slow rate that it's it's basically
imperceptible and so the question is
like mechanistically why does that occur
and so I argue in the article that my
own nuclei are a prime candidate for
that so we know that essentially early
on in the training process lifters
accrue more Maia nuclei from satellite
selves the satellite cells donate their
nucleus to the muscle fiber you gain
more my own nuclei and and that seems to
be one
of the factors underpinning why new
lifters can grow so quickly
another factor underpinning it is you
know if you're untrained just walking
around you are probably below your
maximum my own nuclear domain limit so
there's a fair amount that your muscle
fibers can grow before they actually hit
that my own nuclear domain limit and so
those factors probably contribute to new
lifters being able to grow pretty
quickly and there's some evidence that
suggests that more advanced lifters have
a more difficult time adding more my
nuclei or at least that that process is
progressing substantially slower and one
of the reasons why is that the details
are still pretty murky but it seems like
my own nuclear addition is at least in
to some degree related to muscle damage
that essentially the satellite cells are
activated in response to some level of
trauma within the muscle and kind of go
there to work on repairing that trauma
in the muscle and at some some point in
the process donate there my own nuclei
and so you know the ID I put forth in
the article is you know maybe one of the
reasons people eventually stopped
growing or at least start growing at a
incredibly slow pace is you have you
know all of the things going on with the
repeated bout effect that helped
dramatically reduce the amount of muscle
damage you experience in response to
training and so in the article I was
basically speculating that you know
maybe you get more advanced you stop
getting robust muscle damage so maybe
you can try some strategies to ramp up
muscle damage again and that could help
you add more Maia nuclei which could
then help you grow more and oh in one
additional thing to note as well is that
once you add like once you gain more
Maia nuclei they seem to basically be
there forever there's some research in
like in animals in
who have like had some pretty extreme
things done to them and I believe in
humans after spinal cord injuries
indicating that essentially if all
neural activity to a muscle ceases as
that muscle atrophies it will eventually
start losing my own nuclei but you know
if you go to the gym and train for three
years
and then take six months off say you
probably will have the same amount of my
nuclei in your muscles after that six
months off as you did at the end of
those three years of training you'll
lose a lot of muscle size but that's
going to come from muscle proteins not
from losing my own nuclei themselves and
that's probably one of the things at
least partially underpinning the
phenomenon of muscle memory you know
essentially if it took you five years to
build X amount of muscle you stopped
training for awhile you lose all of that
muscle when you start training again it
takes way less than five years to get
that previously built muscle back and
it's thought that the retention of my
nuclei kind of underpin that so anyway
those are those are some of the things I
talked about in the article and again
the B grow like a new lifter headline
referred to potentially trying to do
things to take time off or recency ties
yourself to muscle damage to maybe then
be able to more efficiently fuse more my
nuclei possibly helping you get over a
plateau and so I feel like that's a lot
of backstory and certainly longer than I
meant to go but it was interesting
though sure hopefully yeah so the
question is asking like some more
research has come out since 2015
not necessarily refuting my own nuclear
domain theory but essentially up to that
point there wasn't a ton of research but
what was there painted a pretty clear
picture and there has been some some
subsequent research come out that does
muddy the water a little bit so to
answer this actual question now that the
background is out of the way first thing
I'd say is listen to the podcast we did
where we interviewed Alex colliery
Turner Turner
this is what he actually studies and we
got into this during that interview
quite a bit so for a more detailed
answer check out that interview and what
I would say just kind of briefly to
answer this question is that I'm I'm
less confident in the ideas now than I
was when I published the article but
when I published the article originally
I made clear that I was kind of putting
forth a hypothesis rather than stating
like this is exactly how everything is
and this is exactly how will work if you
implement these things into your
training I think when I publish it I was
maybe like 80% confident that what I was
saying would work and now I'm more like
60% confident so I still think I still
think odds are better than not that the
information in that article is good but
I am a little bit less confident in it
one thing I will say is that the
research that's come out looking at my
own nuclear domain theory recently is
mostly looking at some of those
variables in like untrained lifters or
untrained animals who begin training and
what I was speculating about in the
article was more about kind of what what
would happen with more advanced lifters
who have plateaued pretty hard as far as
hypertrophy goes so I don't necessarily
know that the research that's come out
that has questions some of the my own
nuclear domain stuff I don't necessarily
know how relevant it is to the ideas
that I was putting forth in that article
but yeah I can certainly admit that the
state of the research is a little bit
more equivocal now than it was back in
2015 I think it's important that I there
are a lot of people that do some writing
in the fitness industry that have it
seems like they feel like you're not
allowed to kind of like build upon what
we know and put forth an idea you know
what I mean it takes a lot of work and a
lot of guts to be like yeah I'm gonna
hit publish on this you know what I mean
so
I think it's cool that you're willing to
put that article out and this is before
I probably didn't know each other back
then did we I think we'd had like two
email exchanges about jts articles but
that yeah but that's one of the things
that even in the early days that I
enjoyed about stronger by science and
that the writing that you were doing was
that stronger by science back then or
was it I think the strength it was
definitely still string theory yeah but
in any case it's always nice when you
see somebody who's and there's there's
several people in fitness that's that do
this but when you see someone who's like
yeah I'm not sure about this but kind of
makes sense to me
what do you think you know yeah I think
one of the reasons it was misinterpreted
is not many people write stuff like that
and so you know I mean 90% of the
articles I write are you know here's a
lot of research about something there's
a lot of anecdotes to back it up
we're incredibly confident that this is
the case and will be useful for you I
mean I don't write many articles that
are speculative very few people write
articles that are I think a lot of
people write articles that should be
presented as speculative they still
present them as if it's a sure thing
yeah I tried to make clear in that
article that it was you know just
putting forth a hypothesis and it was
slightly speculative and I think a lot
of people just completely miss that yeah
you do get some fitness articles that
are contrarian right where they're gonna
say I everyone holds this belief to be
true but I'm gonna push back on that but
it is still usually in areas where there
is a decent amount of direct research or
at least nearly direct research they can
draw from and so yeah everyone says this
study says that but I think it says
something else but very few where you're
just really drawing from some basic
physiology and speculating so it
certainly is a daring maneuver to pull
off yeah and and one thing that I'll
note is if you would like a full version
about how I feel about this particular
topic and just things that limit muscle
growth in general you should buy tickets
to the Inland Empire
fitness conference this is what I'm
going to be talking about they're not
just like my own nuclear domain theory
but more generally the question of what
can we surmise eventually limits muscle
growth so instead of just speculating
about one potential mechanism I'm going
to be speculating about a bunch of them
and if you're hearing this right now
just know nothing I say in that talk is
meant to be construed as this is exactly
what's happening it's more just like you
know let's sit here for an hour
and speculate and you know hope maybe be
able to draw some tentative conclusions
but I it will definitely be the weirdest
talk I've ever done and hopefully it'll
be fun okay so I said some nice things
about you so now I feel comfortable
asking you this in that talk what
percentage of your content do you expect
you'll get through before they ask you
to stop talking because time is up well
there's two questions here one is how
much will I get through before they ask
me to stop and the second is how much
will I get through before I actually
stop yeah
first first ones like 70% second one's a
hundred and ten okay that makes sense no
so I mean unless they have people who
are strong enough to to physically drag
me off the stage they might it's going
down yeah so that's a really fun event I
spoke at it last year it's in Spokane I
assume again right I think so yeah very
cool venue Spokane's a fun town I like
that I didn't get to stay too long but
that that's a really fun event a lot of
good people attend it a lot of good
people speak at it very good people run
it so definitely be sure to check that
one out
oh and uh now that I think about it I'm
pretty sure that's what I'm going to be
talking about at oh man I should
remember names the the one in Australia
isn't the ultimate evidence-based
confirm that's it you ABC I was gonna
say JPS but those are the people putting
it on I assume that there's not going to
be that much crossover attendance
between Australia and Spokane I general
try to only like I generally only try to
do talks like two or three times because
I know that I know a lot of people
basically have like four talks they do
and they do them for like ten years in a
row and so the first time you hear him
speak it's like oh that was cool and the
second time you're like oh that's like
the same talk as last year with maybe
one extra slide so I very strongly try
not to do that these very well may be
the only two times I give this
particular talk so if you are either you
know somewhere in near the west coast of
the US or Australia check it out okay
let's let's move on let's do it we have
a question for Eric from Salve question
is sodium bicarbonate has recently
received high levels of press due to its
proposed ability to limit fatigue thus
allowing for increased effort during
high-intensity interval training what
are your thoughts on this for
high-intensity interval training and
lactic threshold type workouts yes so
sodium bicarbonate you know it is one of
those supplements one of the few that
you can say like okay we've got a decent
body of literature where this at least
is fairly reliably improving some type
of exercise now for resistance training
the the evidence isn't very strong but
for Sprint type training I think it is
quite strong
now what sodium bicarbonate what sodium
bicarbonate is doing is bicarbonate is
is our main extracellular buffering
system for acidity so when we're doing
really high intensity exercise we
generate all these protons the the local
metabolic environment becomes quite
acidic and the pH drops and we have to
have some way of basically clearing that
out and what's the word buffering that
acidity so what happens is you know
we'll give the sodium bicarbonate in an
effective dose people will do some
sprint work they're able to accommodate
that increase in the production of
protons more effectively so even though
they're doing a similar amount of work
they are creating a less
a less acidic local environment
metabolically speaking and so what that
allows them to do in many cases is
achieve just a little bit a little
slightly higher work output during that
particular sprint workout okay so
essentially what we're doing here is
because sodium bicarbonate is a very
effective extracellular buffer we're
shifting that whole lactate threshold
upward so to achieve a similar level of
acidosis more work is ultimately
performed so for many different types of
sprint related outcomes we do have
research indicating that properly dosed
sodium bicarbonate will enhance sprint
performance to some extent but there are
some potential downsides or at least
shortcomings
one potential shortcoming is that sodium
bicarbonate if you use it consistently
it may not necessarily enhance the
adaptations to your sprint type training
so there was a study that Mike Zorro's
covered in mass the study was by Sigler
and colleagues in 2018 and they were
looking at sodium bicarbonate they
looked at some acute effects and then
they looked at kind of chronic training
adaptations what they found is that
bicarb the sodium bicarbonate certainly
it reliably induces acute alkalosis it
kind of increases the pH of the blood to
a small but physiologically meaningful
extent now they found that repeated use
kind of consistent use throughout a
training program didn't seem to enhance
training adaptations they were looking
at like leg extension one rep max and a
bunch of like very mechanistic torque
related variables of the knee extensors
however even the acute effects in that
study based on the outcomes they chose
weren't particularly impressive but but
the general my general reservations when
it comes to using sodium bicarb as you
know a strategy you're going to lean on
to promote training adaptations is I
think I think it's it's quite likely
that the the acidosis and the general
metabolic
chaos all those metabolites that are
generate
during really high-intensity interval
training there almost certainly driving
adaptations to some extent when we're
talking about bolstering that anaerobic
metabolic system so you know you can
shift the lactate threshold upward and
certainly in the short term you're
probably going to be able to achieve
more work in a really fatiguing maximal
sprint task but you're probably when we
look at it as a training aid for
training adaptations you're probably
just putting yourself in a position
where you have to do more work to elicit
the same stimulus for those metabolic
adaptations that should bolster your
ability to sprint over time now I I
don't think I don't have any reason to
believe that it would inhibit your
adaptations to training so we do see
something like that when it comes to
antioxidants right so with really high
dose like vitamin C and E for example
especially vitamin C there have been
studies where they say oh so when we do
this really challenging exercise there's
all this oxidative stress that might
contribute to you know the residual
fatigue and soreness and muscle damage
and all that stuff what if we do really
high doses of antioxidants before
training to try to mitigate the
production of all those all that
oxidative stress and what they find is
with a really high dose vitamin C they
can certainly attenuate the acute
production of oxidative stress however
what they found out was that oxidative
stress does seem to play an important
role in promoting training adaptations
to the training bouts so there are
studies showing that in young healthy
people who are who generally don't have
a bunch of oxidative stress at baseline
it's actually a little bit
counterproductive I don't expect that
that's the case for sodium bicarbonate
but I think a lot of people are under
the impression if I use sodium
bicarbonate before training I shift my
lactate threshold I get a little bit
more work done in my training session
that is going to create you know
proportional improvements in my
adaptations to this program when it
comes to my sprinting capacity and
I'm a little bit skeptical that that's
the case I I don't think it's gonna
hinder adaptations but if there is an
increase in training adaptations I don't
think it's gonna be as big as people
expect it to be and it certainly won't
be in proportion to the short term you
know single dose acute effect that we
see with sodium bicarbonate and
performance I think the more general
point is certainly a very important one
where there's so much acute research
about things that you know maybe improve
performance during a single exercise
session or maybe slightly improve
recovery and a lot of times when you
read those studies they'll say like well
this improved acute performance we know
that you know this proxy of workload for
acute performance is associated with
this beneficial training outcome so
since this improved this given proxy we
think it very well may improve training
outcomes as well and then when those
studies get picked up in the blogosphere
and social media they'll say well you
know this was just a single session and
it improved performance within that
single session but you know it's pretty
clear that everyone should be doing this
or taking the supplement because you
know if you're getting three extra reps
per set that has to mean more strength
gains more muscle growth over time and
and the thing is like that line of
thinking doesn't have a strong track
record it worked out really well for
creatine even though creatine promotes
hypertrophy via other mechanisms other
than just improving acute performance
but yeah you could say that that idea
hit once but hasn't really seemed to do
that that well for high dose
antioxidants yeah it improves some
markers of recovery via limiting
oxidative stress so you know maybe
volume in a week could be higher but
it's also mechanistically like
inhibiting anabolic signaling so it
actually decreases muscle growth similar
with cold water immersion that tends to
pretty reliably improve recovery as well
also limits muscle growth
same thing with in sets that improves
recovery from training limits
so growth other things that have been
shown to improve acute training
performance either just don't have much
data on them or the data is pretty
equivocal isn't there one longitudinal
study on citrulline now there is but
it's got some pretty big limitations
that's what I felt so not much there
caffeine acutely improves performance
but not really any longitudinal research
looking at caffeine exclusively there
have been some studies looking at
pre-workout formulations that include
caffeine but you know we know that
caffeine improves performance acutely
and strangely there haven't been any
longitudinal studies looking to see
whether that actually does anything for
gains in the long-term so yeah just just
that whole idea of you know we found
this thing that acutely improves
performance or acutely improves recovery
therefore it's necessarily going to lead
to better training outcomes I would just
say slow your roll there buddy because
that whole concept if anything works in
Reverse for things that improve recovery
kind of on average based on what's been
studied so far and has a has a spotty
and inconsistent track record for things
that improve acute performance as well
yeah another thing to keep in mind in
our mass internal review this month we
kind of had a little chat about this but
the general question of how close to
failure do you need to get to really
effectively promote hypertrophy and when
you consider like you know a lot of
these studies they're showing like oh
you can increase your maximum number of
reps from eleven and a half to 13 with a
supplement it's like well if you're
going for hypertrophy you probably only
need to do ten and then just rack it so
like that to me if you're going down the
hypertrophy route for some of these
supplements I think I think that aspect
really makes you question if we don't
even need to go to failure to induce
hypertrophy why would it really be
important for us to extend our failure
window by a rep and a half yeah and I
think
I think in general my speculation kind
of mirrors yours like what you were just
talking about like maybe sodium
bicarbonate improves performance but
very well could just mean that you have
to do more to achieve the same effect I
kind of think that's how a lot of these
things are gonna work out
I think caffeine might be an exception
because it seems to mostly work by
reducing perceptions of fatigue so maybe
it just lets people actually push harder
but isn't actually doing anything
mechanistically to effect like metabolic
fatigue or something like that even
though it does have some effects on like
glycogen and carbohydrate utilization
and whatnot
so who knows maybe maybe that would be
the same story as well but yeah I kind
of think that with things like
citrulline malate sodium bicarbonate
beta alanine all of those things they're
essentially helping to like
theoretically reduce some of the
metabolic stress your muscles experience
and so I kind of conceptualize
hypertrophy as kind of one part
mechanical tension and one part
metabolic stress or I mean if it was
like a cocktail recipe maybe it's like
three parts mechanical tension to one
part metabolic stress in terms of like
what's actually driving it I don't
really know but let's just say that
those are the two biggest variables I
think that you know if it's just about
using the same load and being able to do
more reps before failure I kind of think
mechanical tension is going to be
similar regardless and then if the
second aspect is metabolic stress total
reps performed is going to be a proxy
for metabolic stress but not necessarily
if you're changing inputs that also
affect metabolic stress so you know
let's say theoretically the optimal
number of reps for hypertrophy is three
Shia failure if three if three Shia
failure occurs at ten reps or twelve
reps you know you would be reaching the
same metabolic point by but just doing
more work in the process yeah I'm kind
of with you I don't I don't necessarily
know that we
should assume that it would improve
results in the first place yeah it's
it's interesting I mean I really do if
you have the keys to an exercise science
lab out there these are very very
feasible studies that could be done that
would be really cool I mean you could
fund a caffeine muscle adaptation study
with $20 probably yeah if you already
had that's the one I really want to see
yeah I'd love to see somebody just say
hey caffeine or placebo
you know before training for X number of
weeks let's see if this really pans out
one other thing if you are gonna go that
sodium bicarbonate route because like I
said it will acutely enhance performance
for certain sprint type activities
something I've mentioned on the show
before you want to keep an eye out for
the GI issues that people report with
sodium bicarbonate if you go a little
too high with the dose it can be pretty
unpleasant there was a study very
recently within the last couple months
that was called the effects of a novel
by carbonate loading protocol on serum
bicarbonate concentration a randomized
controlled trial and what they do within
that paper is they lay out a way to dose
sodium bicarbonate in a way that was
shown to be really effective in terms of
minimizing the GI distress but still
allowing you to achieve a really high
level of blood bicarbonate so you can
look into that basically what they did
is they started this dosing protocol 19
and a half hours before the test and
just kind of incrementally did these for
increasing dosages with you know as the
the testing time approached so they did
like 110 milligrams per kilogram 130
hundred and 60 and 200 every few hours
or so so that's something you might want
to look into if you go that route and
additionally I mentioned that
bicarbonate is our primary extracellular
buffer but beta alanine supplementation
increases muscle carnosine levels and
carnosine is our main intracellular
buffer buffer for muscle so there are
some studies showing that combining
sodium bicarbonate with beta alanine
might be a little bit more effective
than one or the other alone but you do
run into an you run into a situation
there where the returns are fairly
diminishing and you know you put
yourself in this position where you're
taking it bicarbonate dose or a beta
alanine dose like every few hours
because beta alanine you're gonna want
to split it into at least three or four
doses a day sodium bicarbonate if you
want to avoid those GI issues you're
gonna do the same the timing of those
doses aren't potentially going to be
similar but maybe not exactly so it does
become a very cumbersome way to get a
small increase in your acute performance
so that informations out there but I
don't know if I'd spend a whole lot of
time or effort stressing about it
yeah I mean I I could definitely see it
being useful for like competition
purposes sure no you know probably not
for like power lifters or weight lifters
but if you're a strongman athlete and
there's going to be several like reps to
failure events or you know like a like a
loading event where you're probably
gonna be moving for 30 to 60 seconds
then maybe using some of this stuff to
acutely improve performance in a context
like that would be quite beneficial
because at that point you're not
interested you're not worried about the
training adaptations you get from the
competition you're just trying to
perform as well as possible on day of
yeah I'm so like strongmen or like
CrossFitters using sodium bicarbonate
beta alanine stuff like that before an
actual competition you know probably
beneficial maybe a little cumbersome
that competing itself is a little
cumbersome so who knows maybe the juice
would be worth the squeeze but I very
much agree that just for day-to-day
training purposes probably not worth it
for most people I agree alright so
another question for Greg here this is
from Joanna Eck in a previous episode
you discussed using chains and bands to
alter the resistance curve and its
effects as it pertains to
for strength I was wondering what your
take is when it comes to using chains or
bands when the goal is hypertrophy yes
oh that's a good question and that is
something that I didn't really address
in answering the previous question one
thing I will note is that if you are
interested in previous questions we've
tackled on the podcast you can go to
stronger by science comm /qa and there's
a like linked archive page of all of the
questions that we have previously
covered but anyway so yeah someone
previously asked about accommodating
resistance and its effects on strength
gains so I am Dan hauled about that for
probably entirely too long but I didn't
address hypertrophy one of the reasons I
didn't is that that is not what the
research is interested in it is a little
frustrating to me because like if you're
doing a longitudinal training study
that's a pain in the ass it's a lot of
work in my opinion like I I'm not
someone who I'm not someone who will
just say like take every measure
conceivable so you can slice it up and
get four papers out of it or you know
just have a lot of different variables
you can try to P hack but for a
longitudinal training study it's such a
pain in the ass like major chronic
measures that may actually matter to
people I say take them all and so you
know if your if your lab has like an
ultrasound where you can measure changes
in muscle size if you're doing a
strength study just measure muscle size
as well it may or may not differ between
groups but you're already doing the work
get that measure if you don't have an
ultrasound but you have a DEXA get leg
lean mass it's not as good but at least
it's something if you don't have either
take take like limb circumference --is
and skin fold thicknesses like there's
regression equations you can use to kind
of predict changes in cross-sectional
area not as good as either DEXA or
ultrasound assessments but you know
again at least it's something but anyway
a lot of studies don't do that
and specifically a lot of the studies on
accommodating resistance using bands and
chains just they assess strength
outcomes and don't even attempt to
assess hypertrophy outcomes so I don't
really say anything about it then just
because there's not direct research to
fall back on but the question was asked
and so speculate I will so first things
first kind of the whole the whole theory
behind accommodating resistance and why
you might want to use it in the first
place is that it helps match up the
resistance curve with your strength
curve and so by that I mean that in most
of the exercises you do you're weaker at
the bottom and stronger at the top that
that's not true for some exercises like
let's say pull-ups but for things like
you know squats generally deadlifts even
though some conventional pullers are
weaker at the top benchpress shoulder
press
pretty much anything in like the
squatting and pressing categories at
least most people are going to be quite
a bit stronger at the top of the rep
than at the bottom and so when you
attach chains or bands to the bar it
helps match up the resistance curve with
your strength curve instead of moving
400 pounds through an entire range of
motion where at the weakest point you
can lift 400 pounds and at the strongest
point you can lift 500 pounds you can
put you know 80 pounds of band tension
on the bar with none at the bottom so
that at the bottom it's 400 pounds it's
still very challenging at the top it's
480 which is much more similar to the
500 pounds of force who would be capable
of producing so that's kind of what
accommodating resistance does for you
and so the question is could that help
with hypertrophy and I think in general
just to to tip my hand a little bit I
think as long as you're smart about it
the effect one would at least assume
would either be neutral or positive I do
think if you apply it poorly it could
have a negative effect so to start with
we
there's a reasonably decent evidence
that one of the things that matters for
hypertrophy is exposing muscles to load
through a stretched position so if you
look at research on full range of motion
versus partial range of motion even if
you equate to like a range of motion
specific one rep max people tend to grow
more when they train through a full
range of motion and one of the
speculated reasons why is that it's not
just tension on the muscle that matters
its tension like tension in a stretched
position kind of plays a
disproportionate effect so you know if
you put the same amount of effort into
training full squats and half squats
generally your quads are going to grow
more doing full squats because you are
load loading your quads through a
somewhat stretch position and so I think
one way that you could kind of shoot
yourself in the foot using accommodating
resistance is if you used way too much
of it so you know if you put so much
band tension on the bar or so much chain
weight on the bar that the lockout
becomes a limiting factor then
essentially what you're doing at that
point is limiting the load you can place
on yourself when your muscles are in a
stretch position so you know let's say a
good training weight if you're just
doing free weight bench press is 200
pounds if you put and let's say you can
barely just barely lock out 300 pounds
if you were doing like a four board
press if you put like 300 pounds of
chain weight on the bar or something
ridiculous like that then you know you'd
essentially not be able to put any
straight weight on the bar so you want
to be challenging yourself at the bottom
end of the bench press it would be super
hard at the top and you know you
essentially wouldn't be exposing your
pecs triceps front delts to substantial
loading in the stretch position
and yeah I think that that could
probably do more harm than good when it
comes to hyper trophy that is obviously
a somewhat ridiculous scenario the
people I see using accommodating
resistance these days aren't that dumb
about it but I like in this could just
because I'm old and I've been lifting
for a long time I remember when I got
into it during like the heyday of
Westside people heard Louis say Oh lots
of band tension is good and they took
that too you know level a million and
would just put like hundreds and
hundreds of pounds of band tension on
the bar and so like you know they would
effectively not be moving any weight at
the bottom of a bench press or bottom of
a squat and then would be straining to
lock out like the last two inches which
is dumb I don't think many people do
that anymore but if that is something
you do yeah I don't think that's that
good for hypertrophy so now let's
address kind of a more normal use
scenario so let's say you do you are
using appropriate accommodating
resistance the movement is similarly
challenging throughout or maybe still
slightly more challenging at the bottom
but it's not just stupid easy at lock
out that's kind of what you're aiming
for with accommodating resistance I
think at that point one could make an
argument if you think tension through a
stretched position is kind of the more
important thing that it wouldn't really
do anything good or bad for hypertrophy
it would be just as good as training
with straight weight and there is some
reason to believe that that would be the
case so there aren't that many studies
comparing isotonic resistance training
which is you know the type of most
people do most of the time squats
deadlifts curls etc with isokinetic
resistance training which is essentially
using machines to accomplish what you're
trying to do with bands and chains you
can tell the Machine you know I want to
extend my knee at 30 degrees per second
you kick out as hard as possible and it
gives you the amount of resistance
required to not be able to exceed 30
degrees per second
the extension torque so you know at the
start maybe it's not giving you quite as
much resistance as you're able to kick
harder it gives you more you're a little
bit weaker right at full knee extension
so it gives you a little bit less there
but it essentially perfectly matches
resistance to torque output and so
that's kind of doing exactly what you
want bands and chains to do and there
aren't that many studies comparing
isotonic and isokinetic resistance
training and their effects on
hypertrophy but the stuff that's out
there kind of suggests that isokinetic
resistance training doesn't improve
hypertrophy results relative to isotonic
training which kind of makes me think
that accommodating resistance probably
won't positively affect hypertrophy
either probably not negatively affected
but you know kind of giving you the same
overall results one could make the case
that it would be beneficial so another
potential mechanism or at least like
proxy measure associated with
hypertrophy is level of muscle
deoxygenation so there was a study that
I wrote about in Mass a couple years ago
lead author was Gotoh and it was looking
at like full range of motion versus
constant tension partial range of motion
triceps extensions and so one group was
training from zero degrees of elbow
flexion to a hundred and twenty so
that's pretty full range of motion the
other group I want to say was keeping
elbow flexion between 90 degrees and 30
degrees so not going down quite all the
way and also not walking out all the way
and they found that the partial range of
motion group experience more triceps
hypertrophy and also within both groups
and when pooling both of the groups as
well they found that the total amount of
muscle deoxygenation
experienced during the training session
was positively associated with the
amount of hypertrophy that took place
and so if you know if that is a decent
proxy for hypertrophy or at least
something contributing to I per trophy
one could then potentially make the case
that accommodating resistance would be
possibly beneficial because essentially
like you're never fully relaxing your
prime movers when you're you know
benching squatting whatever but near the
top you can kind of relax a little bit
you don't have to put that much effort
into it
and so maybe that's you know giving the
chance for more oxygen to get into those
muscles clear some of the waste products
out and you know maybe constant tension
is like a super good thing for
hypertrophy and so with accommodating
resistance it would keep more tension on
the muscles through a longer range of
motion I still think that if you're
performing reps as a power lifter would
with like a clear distinction between
the end of one concentric and the start
of the next eccentric where you know
you're standing at the top of a squat
for like two seconds to catch your
breath before you do the next rep I
still kind of think that that would
negate any of the benefits of like
constant tension type benefits that you
may be able to get from accommodating
resistance but if you're doing like
bodybuilders style reps if one assumes
body builder style reps is kind of more
of a constant tension approach then I
could see I could see accommodating
resistance possibly making that even a
little bit more effective because you're
making the muscles work harder through a
longer range of motion which may lead to
maybe more muscle deoxygenation and
maybe more hypertrophy like I said since
the isotonic versus isokinetic research
does kind of speak to that directly I
don't like I would prioritize that over
my mechanistic speculation about muscle
deoxygenation so I kind of think that it
wouldn't necessarily improve hypertrophy
either but also when it hinder it but I
am open to the idea that it could be
beneficial so just to wrap this up
if you're stupid about accommodating
resistance and put way too much band
tension or way too many chains on the
bar I could see it being a negative
but if you apply it smartly I think it's
gonna be neutral to positive I kind of
think neutral but I'm certainly open to
the idea of it being beneficial
especially if you're doing like constant
tension style reps alright so a while
back
Eric discussed the groundbreaking
documentary the game changers and
surprisingly wasn't that big of a fan of
it so let's see he had a question we've
got two questions so one oh that one the
name of the first asker is apologies in
advance correct okay I get it I felt
that that was like a heading you had
okay so we have two questions about the
groundbreaking documentary the game
changers the first is from someone whose
parents very unfortunately named him or
her apologies in advance this person
writes I regret to inform you that the
game changers guy is back destroying the
dude Rogan brought on to represent the
other side they walk through a lot of
the topics that come up frequently on
the podcast so it could so you could
discuss the crunchiest nonsense they
pass off as the quote scientific
consensus that could be awesome
the other question is from Roy Jenks Ron
Ron yeah sorry I can't read Ron Jenks so
Ron says slash asks I watched the game
changers movie recently and was
disappointed to find that much of what
Eric said about the movie was false whoa
buddy
shots fired okay Ron continues [ __ ]
of dis rating Eric the movie the movie
never made the claim that eating animal
products makes you worse at fighting and
it never had any and it never had never
said anything about comparing the
muscularity of cows to humans I even
went into the movie expecting to hear
that claim being made and it just wasn't
there
god what a [ __ ] snake Eric just
making [ __ ] up yeah it gets worse he
continues
did you just miss remember the details
of the film or did you intentionally
misrepresent it my bets on number two
after listening to your review and then
watching the movie it seems like you
argued against what you wanted the movie
to be instead of what it really was that
makes me wary of trusting your other
reviews first of all how dare you
question what what do you have to say
for yourself my other reviews I have a
huge library of film reviews you can't
just throw the baby out with the
bathwater okay so before I begin I want
to apologize - apologies in advance this
documentary has taken so much more of my
life than it deserves and I cannot which
is to say the length of the documentary
yeah and then some okay so I just can't
suffer through more of this but but more
importantly it just doesn't matter okay
now I want to be very clear I'm not
saying that I'm like above it or too
good to look into it what I'm saying is
I don't know how much time I have on
this earth and in the time I have I want
to do things that I either enjoy or
things that bring value I would hate
doing this and it would not bring bring
value to anyone at all okay so that's
why it may have brought value if you
accurately represented it the first time
that that is true so I don't really have
an interest in going through the debate
about the movie because I just to me
that they're arguing over these things
but if you want to have an impact on the
science and how its interpreted we have
systems in place by which you can
participate in the scientific process
usually when this kind of thing happens
and you have the the big Throwdown
debate it's usually just two people
wrestling over a set of goal posts and
trying to shift it and shift it and
shift it and shift it so I really don't
want to go through some kind of point by
point thing defending the
because I don't think that's
particularly instructive because I
already made my opinions on the merits
and the applications of vegan diets very
clear you know so going through this
kind of point by point thing aside from
just being a massive time suck and a
thing that I would absolutely hate doing
and not have any joy from it just when I
want to make up my opinion on the uses
and applications of vegan diets I go
into the research literature and I
procure that and I read about it and
that's where I get my information I mean
it wasn't the person that Joe brought on
to represent the scientific consensus or
like the the omnivore position Chris
Kresser yes do you know about that guy I
don't he's uh so he's not as much of a
kook as like Mercola or someone like
that but he's a COO it's like pretty
fringe stuff right yeah he's he's kind
of like well like not like naturopath
but I don't know one of those like
quote-unquote holistic medicine guys
where it's not saying you should do
holistic medicine as in exercise
regularly and eat a well-rounded diet
like you know you should do I think I
think his current thing is like paleo
but like a super strict version of it
which should also be supplemented with
like a [ __ ] ton of the supplements that
he sells I haven't checked in on this
guy in years so who knows maybe he's
completely cleaned up his act but the
last time I checked in on him was three
or four years ago and like I said he
wasn't like a full-on like mirco
low-level nutter but he was he was he
was certainly outside the scientific
consensus yeah on many things yeah so
like between you know the description
you gave and a person who trains people
self-defense for a living I don't want
to dive into that to make my takeaways
on on the merits of a vegan diet I'd
rather go into the research literature
where you know one of the things that
drove me nuts about the movie is they do
all these
experiments that an experiment with
three people and three conditions is not
helpful and there's absolutely no detail
about the methodology why wouldn't I go
into a study with 300 people an
extremely detailed methodology and a
clinical trial pre-registration that I
can hold them accountable to like this
is just such a not helpful thing from my
perspective but I don't want to
completely cop out so I do want to give
my the the viewpoints I still have based
on the whole thing that we call the
scientific method okay any diet spanning
from vegan to carnivore could suck
vegetables and fruits are awesome as are
many grain products animal proteins tend
to have high quality scores depending
you know no matter which scoring system
you prefer there's a paper by Hoffman
and Falvo in 2004 that talks about
although different ways to assess
protein quality animal products tend to
be more favorable for human ingestion in
terms of their quality score you can
absolute this is important you can
absolutely maximize your potential and
optimize your gains on a vegan diet a
hundred percent you would require a
little bit of adjustment but it's
totally doable if a person on a
well-constructed omnivorous diet
switches to a well-constructed vegan
diet it's not going to be a game-changer
in quotes
they won't see any unfavorable effects
but they're not going to be like wow I
can't believe I used to eat four ounces
of chicken breast a day and now I eat
lentils instead if the whole rest of the
diet stays the same it's gonna have
virtually no impact on them whatsoever
now if you want a point-by-point review
of the film itself Lane Norton's got an
article on it so does meadow Hensel
men's I haven't read them all in detail
because again I don't really care that
much but I'm sure they did a fine job
with it if you want commentary on the
Joe Rogan debate there is a Twitter
thread that Kris master John made I
don't really know anything about Chris I
don't know much about his work this is
not an unequivocal endorsement but if
you want some kind of analysis of the
debate that's a place you can find it
Chris is legit I would come sign for him
so yeah I briefly scan I didn't just
like say all right here's I'd scanned
it looked fine but I don't want to
suggest that like everything in it is a
hundred percent my view so okay now
let's move on to Ron so first of all the
game-changer segment came right after we
said that chase young should be on the
Heisman watch for making the finals the
the finalists list and he did so that's
already one point for our credibility
that's an accurate prediction that
happened ahead of time as we led into
that segment on game changers
I think that's Nostradamus level stuff
yeah that was huge
okay and second of all I gave the the
damn movie two bags of popcorn out of
five that is arguably two more than it
deserved okay so the idea that I just
like came to totally tear this thing
apart is crazy okay so he mentioned the
thing about comparing the muscularity of
cows and humans so when we went into
that segment I made it very clear this
is not a point-by-point kind of thing
this is not me looking at verbatim
quotes this is my general sense of the
film and some of the shortcomings that
jumped out to me okay I think I made
that very clear but that was the the
premise it wasn't like hey I'm gonna
read you Coates in the film and then
dissect them with with publications okay
so what I said was you know they in the
movie said cows have more muscle than
humans but cows don't eat meat how do
you explain that now my intention was
not to suggest that is a verbatim quote
from the film so if you look for it in
the film Ron you are correct it ain't in
there what I was trying to do is give
the general sense of a pretty big
logical fallacy that they that they
tended to imply in a couple
circumstances okay so one of the the
actual quotes from the film I think one
of the biggest misconceptions in sports
nutrition is that we have to have animal
protein in particular meat to get big
and strong and perform at a high level
that's just clearly not true all that
protein you get when you eat a steak or
a hamburger where did it come from it
came from the plants that the cow ate
okay so I didn't intend to suggest that
the only reason cows have more muscle
than humans is because they eat plants
that's a ridiculous thing to say they
are an entirely different species now
Maya
protection of that statement and Greg
you can be the impersonal impartial
judge here I thought you could take that
statement they said and and interpret it
as hey cow seams to cows seem to get big
and strong from plants why can't you you
should be able to get big and strong by
eating what the cow eats without eating
the cow do you think that's reasonably
fair yeah I think I do think that that
is a fair interpretation so that's my
interpretation you know unlike every
person associated with that film I'm
comfortable with the idea of being wrong
on this my mortgage doesn't depend on it
they all have [ __ ] to sell you I don't
okay so maybe that my interpretation is
wrong but that was what I got from it
you should be able to get you should be
able to get big and strong are you but
before someone like fact checks you on
that you do have things to sell but it's
not it's not it's not based on it's not
specifically related to this concept
exactly I'm not have a like thirty
billion dollar stake in a pea protein
company yeah I'm not selling you vegan
diets and I'm not selling you that you
shouldn't be on a vegan diet I just told
you a vegan diet can be absolutely
exceptional if you design it well okay
so I think that those are two two very
fair implications from from that
statement or at least the second one you
should be able to get big and strong by
eating what the cow eats without eating
the cow I think that's extremely fair
that logic is not great okay because if
you tried to test if you do a little bit
of stress testing on that logic it
completely implode okay so we have food
chains and food webs they're a thing so
what if you apply that argument to a
carnivore you know lions eat antelopes
for protein but where does the antelope
get its protein from plants that doesn't
mean the lion can just eat what the
Antelope eats and be fine and get big
and strong yeah that's not how this
stuff works
there are different species that utilize
nutrients differently take it a step
further people people think that cows
need to obtain calories from food but
here's a question all that energy stored
in the plant that the Cowie
where'd that come from it came from the
Sun
so just become a breatharian do
photosynthesis this logic is bad and
that was my general take on on the the
film as a whole is there were many
instances of this stuff where they would
say this soundbite and you'd be like
dude think about the logic that you're
pinning this argument on it's not strong
logic so then they said I was surprised
to learn that all protein originates in
plants cows pigs and chickens it turns
out are just the middlemen that is not
how the term middleman works you know
what I mean like it completely ignores
differences in amino acid profiles
between animal proteins and plant
proteins
yeah like middleman implies you know two
kilos of cocaine are offloaded from a
ship that surreptitiously pulled up in a
you know Port of Miami that gets handed
off to the guy taking the shipment that
gets handed off to the local drug guy
that gets handed off to street dealers
those people between the cocaine landing
in America and you buying it
our middlemen but they are passing along
if the if the chain is good the same
cocaine product now maybe someone cuts
it down with some [ __ ] in the middle
steps and that's bad I want to know
anything about that because I have never
perte Caen in the gateway drug marijuana
but that's what a middleman does like it
passes along the exact same product but
sunlight is not the same as protein and
plants is not the same as protein and
animals like basically Ritter
reiterating what you're saying that's
not what a middleman is yeah I mean so
that would be like me saying like hey I
just bought some fresh steel technically
it passed through a middleman Toyota
bent that thing and turned it into a car
but but my steel came in today it's like
no that's not a middle man that's a
manufacturer the cow is eating plants
turning it into different stuff and then
you're eating the cow so that that was
my premise there again I was very clear
about what were real quotes and what
weren't this time around the stuff about
Lions eating antelopes that's not a
quote that's me
testing the logic and a different
circumstance same thing about cows doing
photos since the
that's not a quote but the general idea
here is there was a lot of implications
in the movie that were based on really
rough logic you got to be able to infer
things when implications are made like
if your significant other comes home and
says you know for once I'd love to come
home and not see a sink full of dishes
that's not rhetorical your significant
other wants you to wash your dishes man
like you got to be able to read between
the lines on this stuff yeah just like I
wash dishes one time three months ago is
not that's not a [ __ ] got'em owed to
you with facts and logic you want me to
do it once I did it once exactly that's
not how you win that argument that's
going to go very poorly for you you're
responding to the the text of what was
said rather than the meaning of what was
said exactly so so that was the quote
about cows now I know what you're
thinking Greg Eric you charlatan you
misrepresented the film and you should
be ashamed well I've got one that's a
little bit more on the nose the same
general premise okay here's a direct
quote from the film this whole fantasy
that we need to eat meat to get our
protein it's actually BS I mean look at
a gorilla a gorilla will f you up in two
seconds yeah you can swear on the
podcast Eric I don't like to a gorilla
will f you up in two seconds yeah
what is it gorillas eat are you kidding
me right yeah these are different
species that utilize nutrients from
their diet entirely differently these
are the things I'm talking about in the
film where they're saying I don't know
cows get their protein from from grass
why don't you gorillas seems strong they
don't eat a lot of meat this is just
absolutely absurd logic that's what I
was responding to and I'm totally
correct okay god you're uh I feel like
you're going in pretty hard on Ron
specifically he says I intentionally
misrepresented this guy I see why you
corrected me saying it was Roy you just
wanted to know I'm going on we just
wanted to hammer on rock listen up Ron
okay okay now there goes another
listener
well he already checked out he's not
listening to this did he say he doesn't
trust any of my film reviews anymore
okay so another thing though in the
interest of transparency here by the way
Ron we still love you I'm just joking
okay so we also he was like hey they
didn't say that eating meat makes you
bad at fighting so fighting was like the
real premise for this whole thing here
okay so the opening scene the narrator
says hey I teach people how to fight or
do self-defense for a living and then we
transition to some kung-fu scenes about
Bruce Lee and and he said you know that
Bruce Lee and and I think the narrator
as well got like you know kind of
attacked or beat up when they were young
and it led to a quest for knowledge
about the ability to fight this is like
the jumping-off point for the
documentary it wouldn't be hard to infer
that they're saying like oh there's some
kind of relationship here between
ability to fight and dietary inputs and
obviously the film is about vegan diets
then he says the whole thing that got
him going on vegan stuff was learning
that gladiators who were you know
historically known for fighting were
largely vegetarian based on the
archaeological evidence that they were
talking about and he says it totally
blew my mind
the gladiators were highly priced
fighters who got the most advanced
training and medical care in the Roman
Empire to think that the original
professional fighters ate mainly plants
went against everything I'd been taught
about nutrition so then this film had a
bunch of different anecdotes the first
one we look at is Conor McGregor vs.
Nate Diaz and they framed it accordingly
they this is these are quotes McGregor
was a big meat-eater
that was like one of the things I said
when they introduced him with Diaz they
said Diaz was on a plant-based diet and
then they showed Diaz shadow boxing and
he looks in the camera and says eat your
vegetables the idea that I'm drawing
some kind of link here it should be
pretty clear yeah that's pretty on the
nose
so the movie didn't shift away from this
sequence of different applications of
fighting until nine minutes in the next
time we see McGregor is at the 20-minute
mark approximately he's covered in blood
and losing a fight tapping out to a rear
naked choke and
then they have a thing of him that it
seems like it's a post-fight press
conference or something along a
post-fight interview you know maybe days
later I don't know he says nine days out
from the fight I started eating two
steaks a day and it just came back to
bite me on the ass you know
and then the narrator says this was the
greatest upset in UFC history and it
turned out Nate wasn't the only
plant-based fighter out there this is
making a very clear implication that
eating two steaks a day was part of the
circumstances that led to a huge fight
upset I mean I I think that's pretty
fair right Greg yeah I think that's
quite fair also worth noting Nate Diaz
is pescetarian but what are details yeah
and then here's another one just for fun
I don't want to dwell on this too much
here's a quote a direct quote from the
movie you're not gonna believe me but
it's in there the more meat men eat the
more quickly they lose their manly
manhood so that's why I came back after
watching this I was like okay I'm not
gonna do a point-by-point what
literature am I gonna review Greg to
fact-check the statement the more meat
that men eat the more quickly they lose
their manly manhood what journal am I
going to I don't know like it just
sounds like a thread topic on like a pro
vegan insel forum is that a thing I
don't know it has to be probably okay so
it's the Internet yeah and I mean like I
said the idea that I would intentionally
misrepresent the stuff that's crazy the
virgin omnivore versus the Chad you gave
me no but like okay so the idea that I
would misrepresent this like like we
said the executive producers have at
least tens of millions tied up in
plant-based food investments
meanwhile the the last paper I published
in a journal was the title was impact of
resistance training program
configuration on circulating
brain-derived neurotrophic factor
response in that paper I listed a
conflict of interest that I'm a writer
and online coach in the fitness industry
how are they related how would I
possibly monetize that I don't know but
I like to be transparent excessively so
there's probably stupid to include that
who cares but the idea that it's like
I'm the one who's got an axe to grind
that's misrepresenting stuff and these
guys got like what 40 million tied up in
vegan companies it's alive give me a
break man okay
and all the experts I looked for
conflicts of interest disclosures like
in the credits and stuff I did maybe
they're in there I didn't see them and I
intentionally look for them so I could
be wrong maybe someone found some
conflict of interest disclosures but
every person they interviewed there okay
that's not literal many of the people
they interview they're a percentage of
their income comes directly from things
that are plant-based provegan
books products whatever the case may be
very conflicted okay so deep Greg you're
the judge who wins me versus Ron uh you
know I think that I think it's one one
and we need a rubber match come on
I definitely think you've run you won
this round but uh we need we need a
rumble in the jungle to to decide this
okay we're gonna get we're gonna get our
people on that bring them on the show
head-to-head you man yeah that's exactly
what the fitness industry needs just oh
yeah another debate they always are so
so useful yeah we need another debate
and then we need somebody to do an
analysis of our debate and get that
published and it'll be sweet dude so
going back to the Rogan thing I saw that
that that discussion had occurred I
never clicked on it cuz I don't care but
like I just did when you mentioned it
cuz it's linked here in our in our
outline it's four hours long wasn't the
documentary like two hours I think it
was under two if memory serves this
Christ yeah so that that's what I mean
when I'm just like you I don't want to
spend I don't want to dive into like
eight hours of the game-changer
Cinematic Universe you know yeah there's
that that's half a workday I know I'd
feel real I would feel guilty if I spent
my work time doing that yeah that's that
would not be a good use of time
yeah okay so I Ron I was just kidding
with the animosity we're cool I hope you
still listen it sounds like there's
probably a low likelihood but in any
case I do appreciate your question
because you know whenever we potentially
get something wrong we'd love to have
people bring it to our attention when I
saw that comment I was like oh god I
actually went back and watched a huge
portion the movie like like I was
actually like pretty concerned I was
like dude I'm did I because here's the
thing about bias you know I started that
segment by saying clearly here's my bias
I'm an omnivore but the thing about bias
is that in many cases it's unintentional
right yeah so I actually did have like
my heart kind of skipped a beat because
like I took like I said I'd take that
stuff really seriously and I was like
dude did I like just completely miss
here everything in the documentary and I
was like pretty concerned about it then
I went back and I was like no that's
that's pretty much what they're getting
at yeah so but in any case you know if
you're listening and you're like oh I
think they missed something or got
something wrong you know we're happy to
to address it and kind of put all the
facts out on the table so there's a good
chance you might be listening to this
and still conclude like you know Eric I
think you over interpreted some of those
implications and you'd be well within
your right to conclude that but I'm
still kind of standing by the way I
interpreted it if that makes sense
sounds fair to me okay so I think we
effectively answered that question so
moving on we've got a brand new feature
on the podcast which is a sponsored Q&A
question so this is a really big thing
for us our first ever sponsored
questions so the next question is going
to be for Greg it's sponsored by the
North American beef egg and dairy
coalition so be sure to beef up your
lunch with some scrambled eggs and a
nice milk steak okay if you want to
learn more about how you can support the
North American beef egg and dairy
coalition be sure to ask your butcher or
your dairy farmer today this question is
from Carrara
I wonder if low vo2 Max slash aerobic
conditioning can hinder progress in a
strength training program
I find myself struggling to improve my
list for a long time now and my vo2 max
is quite low around 25
Speight regular training also just
something to keep in mind the person
asking the question does have mild
asthma okay so first thing I'm going to
say is thank you to our sponsor for this
question
the North American beef egg and dairy
coalition we we thank you for helping
fund us to do completely non-biased
reviews of vegan documentaries so to
start with reviewing karara's question
first off if you have mild asthma as
always with any medical condition first
things first
talk to your doctor your doctor will
probably say to exercise but your doctor
probably knows more about exercise in
asthma than I do
so you know before you undertake a
particular training program just check
with your doctor make sure it's okay and
if there are any things you need to be
aware of your doctor should know that
stuff better than I would now moving on
to the meat of the question can a low
vo2 Max or just very poor aerobic
conditioning hinder progress in a
strength training program I think in
general yes but not super frequently and
I think one of the situations where it
could is one like karara's so she
mentions her vo2 max is around 25 I'm
gonna assume that's ml's per kg per
minute and that is just to put it in
context like quite a low vo2 max for
completely sedentary untrained females I
think vo2 max on average is like 35 ish
and for males it's around 40 and then
for for people who are trained in
essentially anything even an aerobic
sports just because you're having to
exercise like do some form of exercise
for your sport you tend to see average
vo2 s 45 50 plus and then for sports
with a heavy aerobic component it's
going to be quite a bit higher than that
for four elite endurance athletes if
you're not north of 70 you're not in the
game and the highest vo2 ever recorded
tend to be in cross-country skiers and
they can be 90 plus yeah those guys are
crazy
which is yeah that's wild yeah so just
just to kind of put some context on this
and I want to say man I learned this in
class and I may get the number slightly
off but I want to say the vo2 max number
where they say like at this point your
aerobic fitness is so bad that you're
going to have enormous issues with
activities of daily living and may need
like help just with day-to-day stuff is
like twelve and a half
give or take I don't recall it's pretty
low but anyway so just to contextualize
that number of 25 it's not you know it's
not like catastrophic ly can't manage
activities of daily living bad but it is
like a good solid ten ml's below like
the sedentary female average and
probably about half that of athletes and
virtually any sport even an aerobic
sports so if you're dealing with a vo2
like below 30 like in the 25 range at
that point it it I think it's very
likely that it could be limiting
performance in the gym just simply
because as we've talked about on this
podcast before resistance training is
quite anaerobically taxing the aerobic
Lee and anaerobically taxing the the
degree to which that is true depends
largely on how strong you are and how
large of loads you're lifting because
it's going to depend on work rate and so
work it's going to have a component of
both how far you're moving the the
resistance that you are the timeframe
you're doing it and but then also just
the sheer amount of weight you're
lifting so you know if you're squatting
600 pounds for 10 reps that is three
times as energy
intensive squatting 200 pounds for 10
reps so it is going to be tougher for
stronger people but even like just
general compound lower body exercises
even if you're not particularly strong
just doing normal training sets is
probably going to be enough to be quite
taxing and exhausting with your aerobic
system possibly limiting performance if
your vo2 is like 25 so in this
particular case if someone has a very
very low vo2 I do think it is quite
likely that that such poor aerobic
conditioning probably is limiting your
ability to gain strength and gain muscle
so what I would recommend what I would
recommend in a situation like that is to
do some dedicated aerobic training try
to get that vo2 max up in more so try to
get like your absolute lactate threshold
up it's probably more important but
that's going to be associated with vo2
max to some degree anyways but yeah just
trying to get in generally better
aerobic shape doing some cardio will
probably help you out something you can
do in the mean time which I'd strongly
recommend just as kind of like a
band-aid approach while you are
improving your aerobic conditioning it's
just doing more like machine training
and single joint stuff so you know if
your aerobic conditioning is going to
limit your ability to do a hard squat
workout it's probably going to be much
less likely to limit you you know just
getting after knee extensions and leg
curls just because the total resistance
you're dealing with is lower the total
work performed is lower and therefore
the stress you can place on the muscles
like the local musculature you're trying
to get stronger and grow it's still
going to be quite high but the systemic
metabolic challenge is going to be
considerably lower so it's going to be
less of a challenge for your you know
general aerobic conditioning which is
what vo2 measures so yeah work on
improving your cardio
and doing single joint training for the
time being especially for lower body
stuff is what I'd probably recommend so
as I mentioned I think there's two
scenarios where aerobic conditioning
could limit you one is a situation like
karara's where you just you know are
coming into this with very poor aerobic
conditioning which is totally fine
that's trainable you can work on it the
other scenario where I think it could be
a limiter and we've talked about this on
the podcast before is if you are quite
strong like very very strong which you
know I like to think applies to a lot of
our listenership but realistically
probably doesn't like if I was just
putting a random number on this like
unless you're squatting pulling six
seven hundred pounds like this probably
doesn't really matter to you all that
much but like I mentioned the the total
amount of weight you're lifting is
largely going to dictate how energy
intensive training is and how much
that's going to impact both aerobic and
anaerobic like challenge of the training
session and you know let's say you have
a typical vo2 for an anaerobic athlete
maybe in the 45 to 55 range which is
good that's better than the typical
person but just like the sheer energy
cost of say doing traditional
hypertrophy training if that traditional
hypertrophy training involves like
multiple sets of ten to twelve reps with
five six hundred pounds like dude energy
cost of that is [ __ ] insane
so I do think that it's not unlikely
that really really strong lifters could
be limited by poor conditioning and you
tend to see a couple workarounds of that
or for that one is just kind of just
kind of trying to find a minimum
effective dose and just roll in with
that you tend to see in terms of like
total relative training volume you tend
to see it being fairly low with new
lifters ramping up in intermediate
lifters and then kind of tapering off a
little bit again in
really really advanced lifters so I
think that may partially be a workaround
for aerobic conditioning becoming a
limiting factor for just how much work
they can tolerate in a session another
thing you tend to see is just longer and
longer rest intervals so like you know
the the anaerobic challenge of say a set
of ten at 500 pounds is gonna be really
really high and maybe you used to be
able to do sets of ten with three
minutes between sets and now it takes
ten as long as you're taking that time
to rest you know you can probably get it
done your workouts are going to be
longer which may or may not be doable
for some people just depending like how
busy your life is whether you have a
family or not whatever but you know
that's another workaround as well and
that's another thing I'd recommend to
carrere as well if if she has time to be
in the gym more
you know just simply resting longer
between sets will probably be helpful
also so yeah to just reiterate what I
just said to wrap this question up if
your aerobic conditioning is very poor
it can certainly I think it can
certainly limit strength and hypertrophy
doing dedicated aerobic conditioning
work will probably help you out and in
the meantime while you're bringing it up
do single joint training because you'll
still be able to stress the local
musculature you're trying to train with
exercises there that are going to have a
lower energy cost systemically and the
other scenario where I think aerobic
conditioning could limit progress is for
people who are already quite strong
aerobic conditioning I think could be
beneficial or it could start becoming
counterproductive in that population
just because you are so highly trained
you may be a little bit more likely to
like lose a little bit of muscle if you
do any sort of cardio like it's it's a
slightly more fragile state because you
are you are a more well tuned machine at
that point but certainly just resting
longer between sets will will probably
be pretty helpful and just doing some
light cardio it's probably gonna be fine
yeah I the other day I was actually
thinking about this
I used to you know everything I did was
on a college campus I lived near it so I
could walk into work at the beginning
the day walk to meetings walk home do I
don't move anymore at all
yeah I mean I was thinking about this
the other day I was like I need to start
moving intentionally because otherwise
you know days when I work from home I
actually do not move
it's really quite frightening so I I
mean I think I'm one of the people that
I would probably benefit from from doing
some structured cardio now because it is
it has gotten very bad oh yeah I mean I
think at minimum unless you have a
pretty active job everyone should go for
a walk pretty much every day like it
doesn't have to be anything intense but
just get some steps in probably gonna be
good yeah alright that does it for
today's Q&A episode if you'd like one of
your questions answered on a future Q&A
episode you can go to tiny dot CC / SBS
QA to submit any questions you might
have as always thanks for listening and
we'll see you next week thanks for
listening to the stronger by science
podcast now Greg and I are not experts
in medicine or health or really anything
else for that matter so before you make
any changes to your diet and exercise
habits make sure you check with a doctor
or another health care professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it visit stronger by science
com2 check out the products and services
that we offer thanks for listening and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you